bruno kreisky vous faire répondre non à
la reconnaissance d'un troisième genre
ça me perturbe en termes d'éducation
pour les enfants savaient que je suis
merci là dedans depuis 30 ans dans
l'éducation des jeunes donc ça me
perturbait sérieusement je voulais juste
vous poser une question à nos amis je
sais pas s'ils vont vouloir y répondre
mais c'étaient les directs est-ce que
vous avez un copain ou une copine
personnellement je suis bisexuelle
d'accord je suis pas partant sexuelle
c'est bon en fait mais sexuelle aussi
c'est à dire que le lapin sexualité la
bisexualité ces deux attirance y
cohabitent mais c'est très difficile à
expliquer donc parfaite puisque chez
bisexuels cette audi c'est pas le même
terme mais c'est difficile à expliquer
donc oui est-ce que vous pouvez pas
intrigué mais vous intégrer dans le
mouvement lgbt parce que transsexuels me
fait un bref il ya plein de choses
évidemment de secteur dans lequel
peuvent s'intégrer les populations ce
pays qui lie pour la france
moi ça me perturbe très sérieusement
votre votre positionnement trouver un
troisième genre je trouve que ça
perturbe beaucoup et je pense surtout à
l'éducation des jeunes parce qu'on aime
ou non aux socialistes qui vous perturbe
exactement dans la vie on est aux normes
une femme a pu on fait ce qu'on veut si
on veut être bi si on veut être
homosexuel si on veut être lesbienne
c'est un autre hall mais je trouve que
on a une identité à la naissance qui est
d'être un homme ou une femme voilà pour
le final et moi ça va très très
catégorie longs mois ce que j'entends
dans l'intervention de bruno c'est qu'on
dirait que ça relève d'une décision que
vous pourriez prendre une décision
contraire mais c'est pas vraiment une
décision que vous avez pas alors
effectivement ce n'est pas une décision
qu'elle soit consciente ou non ça n'a
jamais été le cas et je vais en apporter
la preuve
bon nombre incalculable d'enfants qui se
font virer par la famille tous les ans
parce qu'ils sont transe
je n'ai pas les chiffres précis en tête
mais je vous invite à aller vous
renseigner c'est effrayant
le problème c'est que vous parlez
beaucoup de d'attirance sexuelle et de
et d'orientation sexuelle vous confondez
l'orientation sexuelle et l'identité de
genre alors que ces deux éléments
vraiment à séparer les personnes non
bien sûr qu'ils veulent s'instruire
bruno personne ne sait les gens à la
maison mais cette distinction est
absolument sonde américaine
elle est très importante
il n'y a pas de lien direct entre
l'orientation sexuelle et l'identité de
genre
c'est une personne par exemple un homme
trans donc je rappelle très rapidement
en même temps c'est une personne qui est
menée avec des caractéristiques
féminines mais qui est un homme un homme
tant ce peut être attiré par des femmes
par des hommes par des personnes non
binaire parler d'eux et sanaa les deux
n'ont aucun nom aucune corrélation ci
après vous dit pourquoi ne pas
simplement nous intégrer dans la
communauté bti nous le sommes nous le
sommes et nous l'avons été depuis très
longtemps et je vais même réagir plus en
détail sur ce cas dire je n'ai juste
avant non seulement nous ne sommes
depuis très longtemps mais nous le
sommes depuis bien plus longtemps que ce
que depuis que la transphobie existe
c'est à dire que de tout âge de tout
temps et à tous les endroits la nomine
ariitea exister je vais prendre comme
exemple simple dans les peuples natifs
américains aux alentours des années 1400
il y avait beaucoup plus que deux genres
dans les peuples natifs océanique
il y en avait beaucoup plus aussi dans
certaines cultures et c'est vrai pour
l'asie et c'est vrai pour l'amérique du
sud
et c'est même très pour l'europe en
albanie il ya des peuples qui encore à
ce jour ont une notion culturelle de nos
minorités qui implique plus de gens pas
seulement notion culturelle est aussi
une notion juridique et 10 pays une
dizaine de pays dont l'allemagne
d'ailleurs qu'il reconnaisse l'existence
d'un programme
donc c'est pas seulement culturelle
c'est entrer dans les textes de loi
également tout à fait alors à vrai dire
le problème des taxes de loi c'est
qu'ils ont été fondée sous notre société
sous laquelle on est actuellement la non
binarité ne n'est pas quelque chose qui
a été fondée c'est quelque chose d'inné
qu'on ne choisit pas et c'est pour ça
que c'est important de reconnaître notre
existence parce qu'on est là on est sous
vos yeux on est devant vous et on existe
et le fait et le fait est que dira le
contraire ça serait refusé l'idée qu'on
existe